do you envision any scenario in which
you could be a candidate for speaker
especially with a dead this race look
um this is about a moment in time that's
a decision by the conference I'll allow
the conference to make whatever decision
whether I'm speaker or not I'm a member
of this body I know what history has had
and I can lead in any position it is
McCarthy not ruling out a return as
Speaker as Israel's crisis unfolds the
Republican conference just met on
Capitol Hill ahead of tomorrow's
speakers Forum joining me now as one of
those Republicans who voted to remove
McCarthy and Nancy mace South Carolina
Congressman Congressman thanks for being
here um are you are you concerned about
not having a speaker in place especially
when we saw the horror of what unfolded
over the weekend in Israel well for
starters I don't want to politicize
what's going on in Israel I've been
working all day today getting
constituents out of Israel giving them a
plan to evacuate number one number two
we could have stayed last week and
elected a new speaker the house decided
not to and I hope that tomorrow and we
have our speakers Forum that we will be
Swift in our decision to move forward
and make sure that we keep our our
states our communities our people safe
and get them out of Israel and support
our allies in Israel as much as they
need right now well it's not being
political just to ask you know if we
don't have a speaker I mean it's a big
crisis number third in line of the
presidency you know this is could be a
major love to have stayed last week
elected a speaker I was ready to go well
is that part of the problem like not
having a real plan it seems like get rid
of McCarthy and then what was the plan
to also part of it is why is there such
a vacuum of talent why is there only one
person that people think that can do
this we should have multiple people in
line that can take over the job and
quite frankly 75% of the country thought
he was ineffective as a speaker and so
was the right vote at the right time
last week what do you think you'll get
for your vision for the Republican party
with a new speaker and why are you
confident that a new speaker will
deliver well I just want someone that
America can trust that's it at the end
of the day and if we make a promise to
the country that we're going to follow
the law we're going to have a budget
we're going to have spending bills to
support that budget that we follow
through with it and we do the job that
we told America we would do at the end
of the day Americans just want someone
they can trust someone who say speaker
if he does he or she doesn't do what you
like I don't ever want to do that again
it's about what if the same thing
happens well I hope not I have great
faith in Jim Jordan I'm going to support
him for speaker he's one of the biggest
supporters of Israel in Congress and I
believe he's going to be a great leader
but I'll support either Steve sque or
Jim Jordan coming out of it I'm going to
initially support Jim Jordan that's who
I'm backing right now he'll be a
terrific leader for our Congress one of
the things that um I'm curious about is
something that you said about women and
the Republican party and I guess we
don't have the full screen up but
basically you've said that oh it's a
sound bite we have it okay play we have
for example 14 counties in South
Carolina that don't have a single OBGYN
doctor we are going to lose the house if
we don't F tune the policies that we're
working on for women the number two
issue first is inflation I mean the cost
of everything's gone up but the number
two issue are is related to women's
issues and in that soundbite you also
mentioned abortion paternal fraternity
leave I guess maternity something like
that abortion is a number two issue the
district I represent as a republican
woman I know you're in Liberal you're
representing liberal Charleston pretty
liberal place so kudos to be a
republican uh representative but the
radicals on this position are the
Democrats who want abortion on demand
all the way up to being a l abortion up
until nine months right so what again
what's your position there and how
specifically have Republicans been
hostile to women because to make that
kind of comment you have to have
something to back it up oh for sure I
mean I have pro-life groups that I have
done legislation with as recently as as
the first of this year that will will
not work with me now because I am Pro
birth control why can we not talk about
birth control and access to birth
control in this country as I as that
clip just said there is that is it birth
control not readily available in the
United States in is that really I mean
that sounds like a Democrat talking
point no it well I just you just played
the clip where I said that there are 14
counties in my state of South Carolina
that don't have a single OBGYN doctor so
how are they supposed to get access to
birth control now my conservative
Governor Henry McMaster last year when
roow was overturned he got access to the
pill for women from the pharmacy so you
didn't need to do that and so there are
a lot of things that we can do to show
women that we care it's not just always
related to abortion either but I I think
the the point is the most the number one
thing that's most important to women is
the economy it's I mean and I think
playing into all these other issues not
that they're not important to me that
just gives the Democrats a huge opening
against Republicans because the again
the Fanatics are those who want to deny
when human life begins in my view if you
believe in science life begins a
conception well somebody go ask Camala
Harris what her what her end date is she
can't tell you because it's up to nine
months or Joe Biden they won't tell you
that's I just think that's a better
approach for you I'm telling you about
your do whatever you want but um we'll
save our cannabis discussion for another
day can we agree on that we can agree to
disagree on that and I was laughing that
thank God I didn't have my red blazer on
because you and I really would have
looked ridiculous thank you for coming
in you look good in army green great to
see you thanks so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else